they they are absolutely going to go
national with the mandates it is going
to affect every i don't i don't see the
red states escaping this
but the very least you know in west
virginia we are so far removed from
everything that i really don't see
enforcement as being possible right
right and it comes down to the county
sheriff ultimately
right is the county sheriff going to
enforce these things and one thing that
i remember when
uh the virginia governor was making
noise that they were going to try to
pass legislation that was going to
really curtail second amendment rights a
bunch of county sheriffs got together
and were like we will not enforce this
come at us and at the same time the west
virginia legislature or at least one of
the legislators there was like hey all
you county is in virginia if you don't
want to do that come on over here to
west virginia and people act like it's
such a crazy thing but um hello why does
west virginia exist in the first place
because the civil war happened well i
know but they but they had different
political ideas and they split up like
this is not and this is not an insane
idea to have the states uh disassemble
and reassemble in some capacity yo
it's a it's a meme but uh
i think civil war is inevitable i
absolutely do because in boston and
chicago i know people in chicago because
i i'm dumb from there and a bunch of
people i know have been posting on
things on facebook like i'm scared
they're going to force me to do this
it's crazy to hear from people i know
being like what do i do i'm going to
lose my job what do i do
they're going to make me do this and
it's like you have to leave
you have to leave y'all voted for this
that's the funniest thing some of these
people are biden voters democrat voters
yeah and with a smile on their face they
went in there and they rubber stamped
democrat another going why is this
happening to me because you voted for it
right because uh the people voted for
ron desantis i think they're pretty
happy with their choice dude hair margin
though man right remember he barely beat
gilliam barely beat him imagine the
difference in the national conversation
too if gillum had one and desantis
wasn't a voice and then gillum was found
naked drugged out passed out at a gay
like a gay orgy or something like that
and and it's crazy that you have
navy veterans not that there's anything
wrong with that
well
you just think about the kind of person
you you have to choose from in terms of
leadership right an irresponsible you
know partier or a navy veteran
and people almost went for the guy who
was not a leader
look i got no issue with people wanting
to have gay orgies and do drugs i i'm
very libertarian i'm like this is this
is what makes america great you go off
and you do your thing and as long as
you're not hurting other people just you
know leave kids out of it leave us out
of it and you do your thing and you'll
be happy
but when it comes to leadership i think
we need somebody with leadership
experience yes and this state almost
went for gillum
instead of desantis there's a lot of
things about just from this you know i
don't agree with everything desantis
does he's been criticized over free
speech issues
but i would take the military veteran
over the you know drug abusing party or
guy
don't you think though if it comes down
at a federal level that gillum or not
gillum um desantis he'll resist
tennessee governor they'll resist west
virginia they'll resist the federal i
mean look we already have
in practice today across the country
states actively resisting federal law
that's why i'm saying civil war because
look but but but marijuana hasn't caused
a civil war this is different dude
that concept that's the same
there's a federal law and the states are
saying no it's that that's not the issue
i i could care less i'm sorry i could
not care less that's the appropriate way
that's the correct way to say it i could
not care less if california legalized
every drug in the planet and then some i
don't live there i don't care it has
nothing to do with me but when cities
start saying you must undergo a
permanent and irreversible medical
procedure people flee those cities and
they go to red areas
and some of these people are you know
normies they're not going to be voting
some of them might vote democrat but
what you're doing is right now in this
country what did bill maher say there
can't be
there can't be a civil war in this
country because the mason dixon line
would go through nana's kitchen
says the audience but that's because we
had nothing but an ideological
polarization what the vaccine minutes
are doing is creating a geographical
polarization
now you've got people like me who lived
in the philly suburbs who moved to west
virginia because i'm like i will not
comply or live under the boot of these
despots so i go to the place where
everyone's like we got guns buddy and
i'm like i would like some of those guns
too sir let's go the people who live in
these cities who say no to the mandates
have been fleeing and they're going to
red areas so now the the ideological
polarization where you've got people in
the new york area who are mixed now new
york city is hard left
these are the people who gleefully all
line up together to get on their knees
to fellate the state
and then you have the people who are
like i ain't doing that moving out right
so my the my vector on this was
federal law needs to be enforced
so there will be areas of the country
who resist the enforcement of the
federal law it's not it's not the
federal law bro it's the state laws it's
the local laws but you think it's
basically you think that the tennessee
governor is going to be like all right
everybody get vaxxed why would he do
that that's what i'm saying i'm not
saying that i'm saying that mayor bill
de blasio is going to say i'm going to
take away your paycheck yeah and then 20
of the city is going to say we will
leave new york city do it then you're
going to have those 20 that lean
conservative moving into more
conservative areas and the polarization
is now geographical yeah it's
accelerating then you get the june 20
2022 supreme court ruling on roe v wade
the left seems to think roe v wade is
done for it and if that's the case now
you have hard leftist overtly
progressive or communist or socialist
factions in cities
and red states that have become
overwhelmingly red
and then you get a wedge issue blue
states saying we are going to run
you know um abortion clinics in
violation of you know federal law or
whatever and then you'll end up with
people fighting over it so have you
heard my assessment on that regard my my
potentialities i've stated about this no
so
nbc news slate a bunch of left
journalists said that based on the oral
arguments on roe v wade
on the mississippi law the supreme court
will overturn roe v wade june 2022
that's what the left believes i don't
know if it'll actually happen because
who knows many of these conservatives
are going to be like well it's settled
law but let's say they do
what does that really mean well means 12
states have trigger laws which will
instantly ban abortion
then you're going to have the midterms
and it's going to get rowdy
if a red wave actually happens
republicans will absolutely
put forth a bill to federally ban
abortion they absolutely will and they
will have the votes to do it now i don't
know if it's definitive i'm just saying
if the supreme court does this if
there's a red wave
the republicans very likely would do
this joe biden very likely would veto it
then comes 2024.
you now have geographically polarized
regions the cities have become
overwhelmingly blue and subservient to
the state and the red states have become
overwhelmingly libertarian and
anti-establishment
and then you get a donald trump victory
or a ron desantis victory and they say
the first thing i'm going to do is i'm
going to sign the federal abortion ban
and the moment they do like john podesta
asked of the west coast you will see
blue states start to act overtly in
defiance of federal law and seek to
secede or maybe that's too much maybe
modern sensibilities prevent them from
doing it i guarantee you though if we
ever get to the point where there's a
federal abortion ban you will see blue
states defy that and then you will
probably see
conservative and republican executive
authority going in and shutting these
things down which results in a dramatic
escalation of conflict when you have
geographical polarization
plus states defying federal law to the
point where
it's the issue of
babies you know an abortion yeah i think
it's very simple
when it comes to marijuana laws you are
not going to see a conservative be like
we have to stop these dispensaries
when it comes to abortion you absolutely
will have conservatives being like we
have to go in and stop them from killing
babies right you know there is an
interesting moral argument to be had
here about making a union with somebody
who has a different
moral framework for example when the
union was being formed back in
revolutionary times there was a lot of
people plenty up north who didn't want
to be in a country with the slave states
but there was a moral argument to be had
which is if we don't form a country with
the slave states they will then form
their own country and then their country
will be based on this immoral thing and
it'll be left alone to prosper and so
the moral argument was actually to
incorporate those slave states into the
union so that over time the idea of
natural law and natural rights would be
able to overcome slavery and that led to
a civil war but that was a process that
was set in motion and the civil war
resolved that issue and then we resolved
it right so there is a question and i
don't think so i i i think it resolved
slavery in the sense that that was it
and then it took a couple years before
we finally totally purged it but the
conflict of the civil war has never
stopped it's really interesting how
it's it's probably a bit reductive to
frame it this way but you know just
reading history and following the
presidency and the elections when i see
like everyone's like this is all because
of obama when obama got elected and then
i'm like okay so i read about obama and
everyone's like obama got elected
because of bush it's all because of bush
then you go back to 2000 gore versus
bush then you go back to clinton there
is always something that as a catalyst
leads us to this moment of polarization
and i think it's fair to say that in
many ways the civil war never ended
but i'll give you a better example to
understand you know the simplicity of
this it's not a complicated thing it's
not a conspiracy theory it's very simple
there's this really great meme it's not
really a meme it's kind of just like a
tweet
and they say how
um geographical formations from the
paleolithic era affects modern day
voting practices and what they show is
that they're in this in the american
south there used to be a coastline which
layered a bunch of minerals and
abandoned across southern states this
created the most fertile farmland
that so then when the the plantation
owners moved there they brought all
their slaves to this fertile farmland
then when slavery ended and today that
area is overwhelmingly democrat and
always votes democrat so people are
pointing out how this geographical
formation ultimately resulted in this
band of democrat voters in the south so
what i mean to say is i read about the
civil war
i read about was it 1872 or 1876 where
they were they they decided the
president by committee
yes i don't recall this one so this is
um let me see if i can pull this one up
i think it was 1872. it could be wrong
it might have been six
the 1872 election let's see
um no maybe it was the next one
one of these elections was uh decided by
committee and it was because there was a
dispute among uh the states as to who
which electors were real and which ones
were like the legitimate ones and this
resulted in a compromise that ended the
uh um the reconstruction
boy that sounds awfully familiar to a
memo that i heard was written and
presented to mike pence sometime in
january it was 76 yeah
it was a compromise between democrats
and republicans the democrats of course
were the southern slave owners and
racists and you know after the civil war
was over you ended with the union going
and occupying the south and the
reconstruction era and then this
election happened and it was so
contentious that there was fear the
civil war was going to break out again
and so they said what do we do to make
sure that doesn't happen we will
compromise and so they ultimately said
okay democrats i think they gave it to
the democrats right let's see who who
actually became president um
i think it was the democrat i'm not sure
but ultimately they were like this will
end reconstruction or i think they ended
reconstruction in exchange for the
republican getting it
i can't remember um i was reading it
before yeah james buchanan and all this
stuff so uh anyway it was says it was
the second of five presidential
elections in which the person who won
the most popular vote did not win the
election
the result of the main election uh blah
blah blah blah blah blah blah
second of five person didn't win
content
yeah
that's wikipedia i mean
so there we go electoral disputes and
the compromise of 1877. so i started
reading about this and then i'm like oh
wow they were still fighting then you
read about how the democrats you know
fought back after losing the civil war
with the klan then you read about how
this resulted in the civil rights like
this ultimately brought us the civil
rights era and how the democrats decided
to change their strategy in other ways
and it history is really dependent upon
which which political tribe you believe
in the democrats will tell you that
it's at this point in the civil rights
area that democrats realized the folly
of their ways and decided to help those
who are minorities because that was the
path towards winning and the republicans
adopted the southern strategy and
decided to start working with the
racists and uh i don't believe that's
true i don't either the other the other
is the other idea which is a bit more
conspiratorial is that democrat
politicians realized the path towards
suppressing minorities and maintaining
their racism was to control these groups
and thus they felt that that was you
know their path forward i mean matt
stoller we've talked about matt before
uh he wrote an amazing book where he
outlined i believe the guy's name was
fred dutton i could be wrong on that uh
where he was a democratic strategist in
the 60s and he wanted to capture the
vote of
minorities and homosexuals and
independent women and feminist women
because he believed that that was the
way to gain power and they wanted to
become anti-white male and that was the
turn that happened in the 60s and the
70s and we still see that play out today
i mean the staff really freaking
who was that um they ran against who who
was that where it was the landslide it
wasn't um it wasn't it was news who ran
against nixon
old water no no who no no reagan mondale
i think right megan mohandale yeah
mondale was the guy who's like i'm gonna
form a coalition of of the minorities
and the women and the downtrodden and
then he got like obliterated
in the election here's what people need
to understand about these elections so
this wasn't uh 1980 it was 1984 right i
think so
so here's what people really don't get
about what a 49 state uh landslide is
1984 election come on was it minnesota i
think it was the one look at all these
wikipedias got everybody
uh was it where's the united states
come on wikipedia there we go united
states
yep it was walter mondale and reagan and
you know what people don't realize first
when i say 49 state landslide you what
do people imagine they imagine out of
100 million people 90 million people
voted one one direction and everyone's
cheering and celebrating and saying this
is the guy we wanted and we all in
agreement this country is unified yeah
it was not that wasn't it wasn't like
that at all and so younger people don't
get this
ronald reagan got 54 million votes to
walter mondale's 37 million it was 58 to
40 percent
so
absolutely decisive in the era where
we're used to things being 48 to 48 and
decided by 77 000 votes and whatnot this
is
nearly half the almost half the country
opposing ronald reagan but 49 states
granting their electoral votes
to electoral college that's right well i
mean this is why because these 49 state
landslides tend to favor republicans
this is one of the this
you're making a face like it's not true
i i think statistically speaking you
could favor either party but
historically speaking right it's been
nixon it's been reagan right interesting
was it nixon was weren't there three
four nights at landslides we are a union
of states i believe in that
the question this comes up every
election right it's like but the
question we need to ask ourselves is
like how would you induce states into a
union today
you have to give them power yeah this is
about keeping the union together and
this is what people don't understand
about being hardcore ideological even on
a moral level versus statesmanship and
prudence how are you going to actually
get something done and is it okay to
make compromises on certain values here
and there in order to have your primary
values or the one that's most important
to you have success statesmanship is an
entirely different thing than being an
ideologue and statesmanship requires
prudence and prudence is difficult
prudence by its very definition is about
making tough decisions between two
competing interests that you have and
that's what people are facing all across
the country right now when it comes to
do i comply with this max mandate do i
have my kid take the vax if he doesn't
take the vacs and he can't go to school
if he doesn't get educated that he can't
get a job if he doesn't get a job etc
etc or do i stand up for this i mean
this is why prudence
is such a difficult thing to teach it's
a difficult thing to experience
statesmanship is way different
than just writing a book about theory
and trying to say this is the way
everything should be abraham kennedy for
example is not a statesman right he's an
ideologue he's not a guy that knows how
to get things done and make comments
they're overt about it they admit it
yeah there's like i guess there's some
interview where he says we realized that
everything was indoctrination so we
decided why don't we indoctrinate yeah
like why
i get it i respect it that's the funny
thing too like everything
like
is indoctrination yes and it's it's
funny how
there's a lot of people calling for
banning books in schools
i just found that really funny the
critical race theory stuff and i'm like
yeah i don't know if we really want to
ban the books from the schools we want
to ban the praxis of the books right
like the teachers should
explain the books to kids you know the
stuff where it's got people performing
adult activities in them which they did
have in schools yeah that that's a
little different you know you know we're
not talking about ideologies i don't
like the idea of banning books because
of their ideology but i don't like the
idea of teaching the ideology and you
know what's funny is even the book
burners don't even really think about
that because they're like oh yeah
there's this the book the marx marx's
book is in the library communist
manifesto
that's in the library so is adam smith
right nobody cares that they're both in
the library well you can't have them
both if you're a book burner you can't
have both those books in the library
but but it's it's all just weapons how
do you explain to uh zealot you know
what i mean i remember uh
my my whole life there's never been a
real issue
as far as i could tell about i mean
there's been some peripheral issues
about prayer in school like oh it
shouldn't happen but most people were
like okay public schools shouldn't do
that we get it fine whatever but now you
have a new that's a new thing man but
now we have prayer in schools they're
just they're just they're just you know
contemplating on whiteness right which
as far as i'm concerned is no different
right well it's a really fascinating
thing to to see how the woke thing is
really a religion with sacrament and
and and ritual and visual
representations and all these things
that that echo uh religious experiences
and what it really tells me which is
something that i have learned over these
last several years is that
uh
god man you need it it's there you need
it
there's a hole in us that needs to be
filled and we all yearn for some sort of
understanding of the universe that makes
us not feel insignificant uh one of the
most incredible things that i've
discovered as i've been reading the
bible and praying and like trying to
understand it and come to come to some
level of faith is that uh instead of
like coming up with a model of the world
to justify my behaviors or justify my
actions or or perceptions there's like a
ready-made model that unites you with
the universe with creation with living a
good life with having good outcomes and
that is actually really comforting to
know that the system's been in place for
a long time it works for a lot of people
and when you come across somebody that
really believes and really practices you
can feel that energy come right out of
their face it's incredible i don't think
everyone needs religion or needs god
but i think most people probably need
something like they need
some version of this like of this faith
system
i remember i talk i've talked to a lot
of people about you know like
psychedelics and psilocybin and stuff
like that and they're like man people
really need this stuff and i was like
yeah i don't think i do
um
like the people say it's like it's very
good it can open your mind and i'm like
yeah i don't think i need that to
consider new ideas or or change my
opinions and and be open to exploring
this you know maybe that's just me
i personally don't feel like i need to
have any kind of guiding faith force in
my life that being said i do believe in
god but uh that's why you don't feel any
need for it brother maybe maybe that's
it yeah maybe i you know i guess people
who lack that are lost and scared and
confused yeah because if you think about
it you're just a lump of cells on a
planet in a cold dark infinite universe
if you really put yourself in that
person it is but if you put yourself
there for no reason and no purpose
randomly by accident well yeah life's
insignificant and you're facing the
infinite infinite but that's that's
purpose that's not god you know what i
mean you can believe in god and still
believe that you have no purpose
people black purpose
so so maybe purpose is about it purpose
and meaning are two different things i
guess huh maybe some people find their
purpose through god and some people have
nothing and so they create purpose and
ideology you know what's interesting is
that mood follows motion activity is
life and the christians say love thy
neighbor so if you love your other
neighbor and you act it and you put it
into motion and you become active in
this regard it you you get filled with
the love and energy that makes those
questions go away
you just don't think about it because
you're filled with good energy it's
incredible the cult members hope
that once they purge people like you and
i or everyone who's watching they will
have a pure utopia world
because
i'll tell you
communism
can work
it can't scale it's all about scale no
no but at a very very large scale of
even a billion people communism can work
it's very simple you just have to kill
anyone who opposes them right exactly
and so
literally it means it doesn't work
because you have to kill everybody but
that's why they always do it because
when the communists gain power they say
what's stopping us from having everyone
march in lockstep like worker ants
it's these free thinking dissidents yeah
uh my good friend joe norman who is a
complexity scientist and teaches people
complexity science you should check him
out joe norman he's been on my podcast
jack murphy lab a couple of times what
he's taught me is that everything is
about scale
everything is about scale one idea can
work at one scale and it won't work at a
different scale in my family it is
communist from from it's expected that i
can deliver the goods and everybody else
gets what they need according to their
needs and that's beautiful and i love it
it's perfect but as the scale gets
bigger and bigger and bigger you need a
different uh form forming algorithm or a
forming idea
imagine if someone was like a car is a
tool that can go from point a to point b
i need to move three you know 3 000
pounds of bricks and i have a car it
should work right it's like no you need
a different vehicle for that process no
it's exactly right so if our goal is to
move resources from person to person
on a small family level yeah it's great
you're you're a commune you're a family
someone's the boss you know there's
varying degrees of who's in charge
depending on what riches you have and
everyone gets what they need but if you
want to move resources in a large scale
civilization you need
capitalism the funny thing is the left
doesn't know what the word capitalism
means and i think that's part of the
indoctrination
change definitions and you can confuse
people right so it's funny when you see
leftists complain about communism but
call it capitalism right they complain
about
the state controlling resources and
colluding with the powerful elites to
dictate who gets what and they're like
this capitalism man it's like capitalism
just very plainly means and i believe
capitalism came from marx anyway very
plainly means the private trade of goods
meaning an individual can trade freely
as they choose period we are not in a
pure capitalist system by the way not
even close yeah we're in a we're in a
very constructed and controlled economy
right well and the government works to
pick winners and losers and especially
pick losers we're feeling that
you can't even work if you don't do
exactly what we say this is an issue for
sure and of course we've evolved into
like an oligarchic state it's corporate
feudalism and you don't even really
gonna own anything which is what they
want private it's interesting i had a
conversation with alexander dugan a
russian philosopher people calling
putin's lap dog whatever
he and i talked about this very issue
and he said that he wants to get rid of
capitalism and i was like well you know
you might not have a lot of fans over
here in the united states if you keep
talking about getting rid of capitalism
like no no no
i don't mean get rid of private property
i just mean get rid of what's happened
today what capitalism has turned into
and that got that got my interest a
little bit and you know the guy's a
little crazy and he's got some seriously
out there ideas and he's done some
probably pretty bad things but he was
interesting interesting to talk to
because you know he's an influential guy
and i can see how uh inequality the uh
the uh concentration of wealth in the
hands of very few people uh leads to
negative outcomes and and of course we
would want more people to share in the
bounty that we've created but if you
believe in humanity if you believe in
individuals then you will believe in
individual outcomes and you will believe
in differing outcomes and the founders
were very clear on this different
faculties lead to different outcomes and
we need to preserve that thanks for
checking out this segment from the tim
cast irl podcast if you want to watch
live you can check out this channel
monday through friday at 8 00 pm and
don't forget to smash that like button
subscribe to this channel and if you
want more unfiltered and uncensored
content with all of these guests go to
timcast.com and become a member all of
these guests you know and love in
exclusive segments on our website where
we are unrestricted in what we talk
about so you'll definitely not want to
miss it thanks for hanging out we'll see
you all next time